[Musique]
cette semaine a commencé avec la
poursuite du déploiement de la
vaccination dans les yvelines les neuf
centres ont commencé leur activité
parmi ces sites le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et un centre
social et culturel à saint germain en
laye d'une vaccination ouverts depuis le
lundi 18 janvier aux personnes de plus
de 75 ans ce jour-là nadia ministre
délégué à la ville s'est rendu à poissy
un déplacement dans le cadre du projet
de cité éducative déployés sur la
commune objectif développer
l'accompagnement éducatif des enfants
dans les quartiers prioritaires elles
pourraient soutenir l'activité des
commerçants les soldes d'hiver ont
commencé mercredi 20 janvier
la veille les magasins se préparer dans
un contexte particulier avec la crise
sanitaire
la règle c'est l'adaptation des horaires
par rapport au couvre-feu et la
diminution des stocks face à la baisse
anticipée des ventes
mercredi c'était aussi le lancement des
inscriptions sur la plateforme parcours
sup
objectif trouver la formation en études
supérieures pour la rentrée en septembre
2021 pour aider les lycéens dans leur
choix le salon de l'étudiant ouvert de
manière virtuelle le jeudi 21 et se
tient jusqu'au samedi 23 janvier à
distance
[Musique]